okay so as you see we have another guest
what do you think Naruto let him speak
oh wow he loves you it's like holding
your hand and everything anything more
beautiful okay so this is Gabbie that
they're so right like cats do not have
orders it's like the cat oh okay so this
is a the monster and this is another LSD
episode I always want to say LSD every
time but it's like another LSP this was
first one where she served like the main
focus really um and it's an episode
where she's she ran away and this
monster apparently is in this town and
big shock it's her and they try to force
her to apologize to the villagers
because they're like oh come on you
gotta do this and not steal food and
stuff and she tries to she really sucks
at it it was that was the line is very
funny was she's evil she's apologizing
killer I thought that was really funny
line and then they she realized that
she's being a jerk like for real and
that like really apologizes and Finn and
Jake as they Cynthia which is also
really funny like yeah we can do that
budget and so again I thought that was a
really funny line to end on um but sure
you like LSP - oh what do you think of
this episode you know give me - I know
you're gonna say it's kind of like I
actually really loved
LSP when I didn't see so much of her
yeah she's better in small doses yeah
her charm is it for me what made her so
charming for me was nothing other than
that ridiculous voice and you know that
kind of goofy oh my god I'm a princess
whatever Melissa and it's funny but for
an entire episode
all most of that a yes sorry yeah it
used to be like when she would show up
you feel like yes there she is as soon
as she opens her mouth you'd start
laughing
and I realize I mean surprises might do
an impression too is that the longer you
do an impression of only you do a voice
the more it'll sort of wear off and the
more you have to hear it the more you'll
hear sir like the person's real voice
and I think with LSP the more you hear
it the more sort of the emphasis on my
guy I company leather you know and this
one she's talking a little bit more like
this and has to have a little bit more
of a personality going on and stuff and
you lose the comedy of it and I think
you're right there's not really much of
a character to her outside that branding
is and that brattiness cannot last a
full episode it's just ended and yeah
it's not golf or anything but I was sort
of finding myself kind of you know yeah
okay she back yet this is sort of wrap
it up here and yeah that's I liked it
when she was making up the voices of the
wolves that I thought that was going to
fight and they're clearly just wolves
and I also like that the way she's
exiled most likely is just because she
was making wild sounds like it's not
even like whatever Melissa was cheating
behind his back jessica is that me back
Tony yeah I mean the cry is up there
doing it is probably the face she made
this loud sound yeah yeah well no
there's sort of growl innate or to get
that loud sound yeah I mean it's just it
has nothing to do with what she thought
it was oh it was probably to me my
favorite part of the entire episode was
just that whole she's coming up with
this drama clearly it's just wolves
being bold
it's like oh my god she's cheating on
Tony should I tell her you know and it
was funny but again it was a small
little burst and LSP is funny in small
little doses yeah Kelly narrative that's
why we don't have Naruto on every
episode because he's not be to see be
more example of like me
know you love the oh I'm sorry buddy
okay anywho um Jason you hate LSP so I
wouldn't say I hate her but I definitely
dislike her
oh she's annoying she's obnoxious and I
know that's what the character is
supposed to be and they definitely
succeed but like it seems like as the
series is going along she's becoming
more prominent and instead of popping up
for like like a tiny line here timing
line there they're giving her like 10
lines and 15 lines then now she has her
own freaking episode and it's like I
want it now it's good because you see in
ahead do they give her more episodes or
is this can be like like ones dedicated
to her is this kind of the only one from
what every member of hand this is the
assistant I think they give her one more
but that's it I don't remember this I
don't do many more with her as the the
star and I don't remember how they do or
not to be honest why hurt on one of the
commentaries for like the Simpsons
they're talking about episode where Otto
was like the main focus and they
realized that it was a huge mistake even
though every episode being okay but they
said like they just had a lot of fans
already like we love Otto the kids
really liked Otto get more Otto and so
and they gave him an episode they're
just like no this is a character that's
only funny for a whiner yeah and that's
what I feel for LSP is I mean she'll
come on and it'll be a funny line here
there but then it'll be kind of like
she's on here for too long please leave
just go away
yeah for me it was always like the right
amount of time you know cuz you just
have her do a little line and it's funny
and it's that delivery and the positive
and you can get away with it in short
bits because it's only for a line so you
can have those pauses you can have it be
really over-the-top but you can't
sustain that throughout a whole episode
so in this one it seemed like the
oppression was played down a little bit
more for the yeah quote-unquote
emotional moments you know where she has
to learn something but yeah it just was
not it just was not working for me um
it's not like god-awful there's still
funny stuff and it
it's definitely one of those things
where it's you gotta know deep down she
I guess are like the Marceline Finn
thing that they probably like they
shouldn't go this route but your kinda
thing Oh what it'd be cool come on try
it know what you see it it's like man
damn it
trusted my god in this situation I'm
completely on the ice king's level
remember when in hitman the one I was
not here for you're grounded
he talks about uh how about we just
changed who you kill how about one of
the princesses I don't like like lumpy
space Kingdom I mean think about it
even though Finn and Jake don't like LSP
way back when with the businessmen OLS
pees in trouble I can't handle LSP today
this is a business then do it I mean
again that was part of the fun is that
she was so difficult but it's like I get
just those small doses yeah yeah the
idea of actually that sort of put for a
minute fitness like I can't handle her
today nobody can handle her like in a
large amount the idea that we get a lot
of her in this episode is sort of like
yeah I'm kind of not feeling this so
yeah yeah not that great one but it's so
got a few laughs I mean and I do like
how at the very end
yeah so I just loved the way that lumpy
space person princesses crops cuz it
always sounds like she said perhaps yeah
throwing me off is the consistent change
in size like I know that there were the
kids and the adults but when you see
like lumpy Space Princess first show up
they're tall and then when they're Jason
are trying to kill her they're short but
it's just I don't know if it was just
the way LSP was remembering it or if
they just didn't remember how tall or
short they were you know I'll say one
other thing in this episode because I
keep forgetting to bring this up another
episodes uh it starts off which is Finn
and Jake they're just sitting down
just like drinking something and they're
just making up a song and they're just
yet and then phones and stuff like that
I love it when an episode starts off
like that because again it creates more
of this environment in this atmosphere
that even though of course it's total
fiction and over-the-top it's kind of
believable for it feels like a world you
can live in because that feels like
something that kids do and I know we
used to you know we just sort of sit
around we just sort of hum or make up
songs or just whatever if you have so
much energy and you possibly want to do
stuff even when you're resting you're
kind of doing stuff as I can't actually
we actually still do that
we'll go for like an hour or two where
we just like kind of sing to each other
Marie what are you doing like we're we
are so that's yeah cool
yeah no it's just one of those things
where it's like and it does create kavik
it's more of a connection between them
too it just still seems to work so yeah
so not one the best but at least they
had to make up a song in the beginning
narrative closing thoughts
no don't you forget it
oh that boring big old yarn
he's hiding his face to say my boobs let
that saggy see he's gonna be like no
slippery saggy no okay buddy are your
nipples his eyes
no I everyone else's